excuse me what is the nearest star to
our Sun Proxima Centauri and how many
parsecs is it away from Earth 1.3 and
what is a parsec one parts that
corresponds to the distance at which the
mean radius of the Earth's orbit
subtends an angle of one arcsecond and
how many degrees is one arcsecond 135
hundredths of a degrees
Ron if 136 hundredth of a degree sir how
much do you know about the MCTS the
Milwaukee County Transit System
enough to get by how did the Milwaukee
streetcar get its nickname 12 your
contract was granted to the Potawatomi
Native American community which included
naming rights and they settled on the
name the hop and which intersection is
the only stop in the Yankee Hill
neighborhood Jackson nanaka Ron Jackson
and Juneau street corner TV when was
Black History Month first celebrated
well the precursor for Black History
Month was conceived by Carter G Woodson
in 1926 but the first official
celebration was in 1970 in America 1987
in the UK and 1995 in Canada and what
did the Civil Rights Act of 1964 do well
when lyndon b johnson signed the bill on
July 2nd 1964 at outlawed segregation in
public spaces and banned discriminatory
practices and businesses and what day
and year was brown v board of education
past May 18 1954 Roy May 17
who's our country's third President
Thomas Jefferson and who is Thomas
Jefferson's second vice president George
Clinton and who played guitar for George
Clinton's band Parliament Funkadelic
they had many guitarists including Eddie
hazel Michael Hampton and Gary dye
Perman cider but why was he called
diaper man he played while wearing a
diaper made out of the hotel towel prove
it okay
yeah that's
[Applause]